un nom que leur couple est reconnu par
l'état civil en novembre 1999 dominique
et francis était le premier couple à
s'unir par les liens du pacs le pacte
civil de solidarité a été adoptée au
terme de presque dix ans de débats
l'assemblée nationale a adopté la loi
sur le pacs
la première proposition de loi est
déposé au sénat en 1990 un contrat de
partenariat civil proposée par jean luc
mélenchon socialiste à l'époque mais le
projet jugé caduc en 1992 pour les
pouvoirs publics
il y a nécessité de créer un statut 2
millions de couples vivant en union
libre
un enfant sur trois est né hors mariage
aucun droit pour les couples homosexuels
une proposition émergent à mi chemin
entre concubinage et mariage c'est le
cucs contrat d'union civile
c'est un simple contrat qui peut être
passé entre deux personnes du même sexe
ou de sexe opposé et à partir de ce
contrat qui est passé devant le maire eh
bien on a un certain nombre de droits
qui sont en gros les droits quand les
couples mari actuellement succession
propriété le cube ouvre de nouveaux
droits
les français le plébiscite à 72% mais
une opposition politique et religieuse
se structurent contre l'union de
personnes du même sexe
alors s'il faut faire une loi pour mot
sexuellement exactement un droit pour
homosexuels
je veux bien mais c'est certainement pas
le même que pour un homme et une femme
qui vivent ensemble le projet des
socialistes piétine victimes des
alternances politiques le gouvernement
balladur d'abord 1993 puis la présidence
de chirac en 1995
du côté des défenseurs la revendication
ne faiblit pas je trouve absolument mais
scandaleux que on traite les couples
homosexuels les homosexuels comme des
sous citoyens
c'est inadmissible
des mairies se mettent à délivrer des
certificats de concubinage elles sont
250 en 1996 ils n'ont aucune valeur
juridique mais un faisan débat
législatif
le garde des sceaux jacques toubon fini
par trancher la question et pour lui
c'est non il n'est pas question de créer
le contrat d'union civile
il est au contraire question de faire en
sorte que dans ce pays il y ait plus de
mariage il y ait plus de naissances est
ainsi tu l'apprends soient plus forts
nouvelle alternance politique en 1997
sous le gouvernement jospin
elisabeth guigou est nommée garde des
sceaux elle force le projet de pacte
civil de solidarité
il s'inspire largement du contrat
d'union civile de 1992 il sera
promulguée le 15 novembre 1999 le pacs
ouvre des garanties matérielles
patrimoniale fiscales et sociales
il n'a en revanche aucun effet sur la
filiation et l'autorité parentale
[Musique]